would you ever run for office I
certainly hope not I don't want to get
involved in politics it's just a
disgusting sort of life I have friends
that are involved in politics and it
doesn't seem like what I'd want to do in
my life what about running a school are
there any big differences that you think
would be made in a school syllabus if
you were to be the person that was in
charge yeah 100 basic survival skills
how to start a fire how to put out a
fire how you do first aid how you change
the tire on a car some life skills that
are very beneficial obviously Jiu Jitsu
would be in the career I was gonna say
if he was heavily pushed toward learning
martial arts I would be fascinated to
know what happens to bullying rights in
schools Jujitsu will not only help you
from getting bullied it will also
prevent you from becoming a bully
because when a kid's doing Jiu Jitsu
they realize oh I'm a little bit bigger
and stronger I can take this person but
there's someone that's bigger and
stronger than me and they can take me
and so it helps on both fronts